الى هذه الصور مجددا من قطاع غزه الذي
يتعرض لضربات جويه اسرائيليه على مواقع
لفصائل فلسطينيه ردا على اطلاق صواريخ من
القطاع على اثر وفاه القيادي في حركه
الجهاد الاسلامي بالضفه الغربيه خضر عدنان
نتيجه اضرابه عن الطعام داخل سجن اسرائيلي
اذا المقاتلات الحربيه الاسرائيليه لا
تزال تشن سلسله من الغارات الجويه
وتستهدف بعض المواقع الامنيه التابعه
لحركه حماس تسيطر على قطاع غزه
الحركه التي تسيطر على قطاع غزه بحسب بعض
مصادر الامن وشهود عيان تنقل عنهم وكاله
اي اف بي اذا هذا ما لدينا حتى الان من
معلومات هذه الغارات ليس لدينا معلومات
بوقوع قتلى او اصابات فيها ولكن هناك
اضرار ماديه بطبيعه الحال
الدفاع المدني في غزه اعلن الاستنفار قبل
قليل
لمواكبه هذا القصف اما سلاح الجو
الاسرائيلي فاكد في بيان صحفي بدء
مقاتلاته الحربيه بشنغارات على القطاع دون
ذكر المزيد من التفاصيل لمتابعه المزيد
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات